التعديلات القضائيه وما يحدث في اسرائيل
كان جزءا من سجال بين اداره الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن ورئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو عن هذا المشهد
نشر الكاتب والصحفي المعروف توماس فريدمان
مقالا الاسبوع الماضي في صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز وتوماس
الان من واشنطن اهلا بك سيد فريدمان قلت
ان اسرائيل معرضه للانهيار من الداخل ما
لم يحدث تدخل من الرئيس بايدن
هذا ما قلته في مقالك ما هي المعطيات التي
بنيت عليها هذا التقدير
عثمان ما اقوله من محاججه هو ان تحالف
اليمين المتطرف الذي شكله رئيس الوزراء
ابنه نتنياهو له هدفين ومشروعين هدامين
اولهما
اضعاف النظام القضائي الاسرائيلي وقدرته
على مراقبه قرارات الحكومه وثانيهما هو
تفكيك مشروع اصله
والتمهيدي لضم اسرائيل المباشر للضفه
الغربيه ومن اجل ان يحقق ذلك يحاول اضعاف
النظام القضائي تمهيدا لضم الضفه الغربيه
مما اشرت اليه يعني انت قلت ان الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن هو الوحيد هو الوحيد
القادر على انقاذ اسرائيل اليوم ضمن
اجراءات سردتها لكن
في رايك الى اي مدى قد تستمع اليه حكومه
بنيامين
الاجابه حتى الان هم الحكومه الاسرائيليه
تجاهلوه تماما وعندما حاولوا الاستحواذ
على النظام القضائي طبعا اي رئيس امريكي
لا يمكننا نفعل الا قدرا معينا عندما
يتعامل مع وضع داخلي في اسرائيل ويتعامل
مع ذراعي الدوله التشريع عفوا التنفيذي
والقضائي ونتنياهو قد تجاهل الرئيس فيما
يتعلق بالجانب الاستراتيجي الامر قد يختلف
في قضايا القيم المشتركه بعد فعل كل ما
يستطيع نعم قلت في مقالك ان تمرير مشروع
التعديلات القضائيه سيتسبب في كسر الجيش
الاسرائيلي
وسيقوض ليس فقط القيامه المشتركه بين
اسرائيل وامريكا بل المصالح الامريكيه
الاستراتيجيه في الشرق الاوسط ان بلغت
الامور هذا المستوى ونتنياهو ماض في
مشروعه ويتجاهل اداره بايدن كما ذكرت
التومه هو السيناريو
المحتمل للتصرف الامريكي
طبعا انا ساخذ نظره الى الوراء اقول لا
اتوقع المزيد من الخطوات الامريكيه فيما
يتعلق
بالتعديلات القضائيه لكن اما فيما يتعلق
باي صفقه استراتيجيه في نطاق النطاق
المصائح مع السعوديه او مشروع وصله انا
عشت حوالي خمس سنوات في بلدين في الشرق
الاوسط اولا في لبنان ثم ثانيا في اسرائيل
هذان البلازان حقيقه لديهما سمتان
مشتركتان
كلاهما صغير جدا في المساحه لكن لديه تنوع
كبير جدا في السكان هم هم بلدان صغيران
لكن متنوعان بشكل كبير عندما يكون هناك
بلد صغير بهذا الحجم وبهذا التنوع الاسلوب
الوحيد لحكمه من خلال ان تعيش على الاخرين
يعيشون لا غالب ولا مغلوب لا منتصر ولا
مهذب لكن حقيقه اننا نتانياهو قرر ان يحكم
ليس على هذا الاساس ليس على اساس لا غالب
ولا مغلوب بل صار في الاتجاه المختلف هذا
ممكن ان يؤدي الى انهيار اسرائيل كما
انهار لبنان عندما عندما رفضت السلطات
الحاكمه او المتنفذه ان تعيش وفق مبدا
التعايش اذا على المدى البعيد لا اقصد ان
اسرائيل
يصبحوا مثل هنغاريا وتركيا وغير لكن سيكون
مثل لبنان المنهار وهذا هو التهديد الذي
تواجهه اسرائيل على المدى البعيد اذا ما
اراد بلد ان ينتحر كما فعل لبنان او كما
تريد اسرائيل الان لا يمكن لاي قوه اجنبيه
ان تفعل المزيد لهم
اقترحت في في مقالك ان يوجه بايدن وزراء
الخارجيه والدفاع والخزانه والتجاره
والزراعه
الامريكيين كذلك المدعي العام وكاله
الاستخبارات المركزيه ان يوجههم للاتصال
بنظرائهم الاسرائيليين لاخبارهم بانه اذا
ماذا مضى للامام دون اجماع فان ذلك سيفتت
المجتمع الاسرائيلي والجيشه هل تم
الاستماع لهذه النصائح وفق تقديرك هل
تعتقد ان الرئيس بايدن قد يوجه وزرائه
لنقل هذه الرساله
اكبر الرهينه في الشرق الاوسط وانا عندما
كنت
مراسلنا مصر ايتها الكثير من حالات خطف
الرهائن هذه اكبر حاله خطف
رهينه لكنها من صنع يديه هو
اسس تحالفا من اليهود متطرفين
ومتصهنين من اجل الحصول على السلطه لتفادي
محاكمه تهم بفساد وجهه اليه وقال لهم لا
يهمكم الامر انا اتولى زمام القياده هو لا
يملك زمام القياده هو حتى لم يعد في
المقعد الامامي ناهيك عن قياده المقوى في
المقعد الخلفي هذا ليس اتهاما هذه حقيقه
في اللحظه التي تحالفه يهد
بترك الحكومه واسقاط الحكومه اذا لم ينصت
لهم لا هو يقول لهم اي خدمه يبيع ويسارع
الى انفاذ رغباتهم لانه يريد التشبث
بالسلطه اما لتفادي الادانه او اذا ما تمت
ادانته ان يحاول المقايضه ادانته بشيء من
النفاذ من العقاب هو اذا الرهينه الولايات
المتحده تؤكد دائما انها تؤيد حل الدولتين
في رايك ما هو مصير حل الدولتين في ظل هذه
الاجراءات المتسارعه وسياسه هضم الاراضي
الفلسطينيه
والحديث عن دوله واحده يهوديه
محل الدولتين هو في حاله من العنايه
المركزه ويعيش على الانعاش من الناحيه
الطبيه هو الحل الوحيد لكن علينا ان نرى
اذا كانت هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه ليست
شريكا مناسبا لاي حل دولتين على ادوات
المتحده تحاول ان التوصل الى
اتفاقات امنيه مع السعوديه مقابل
تطبيعي علاقات السعوديه مع اسرائيل وتقديم
تنازلات
للفلسطينيين ربما قد نجد انفسنا امام وضع
اخر هذا ربما هو الامل الوحيد الذي يمكن
ادخاله ان نرى تحقيق حل الدولتان عثمان ان
يكون هذا ضمن نطاقي صفقه امريكيه سعوديه
تستطيع
ادخال المزيد من الحوافز الى الصفقه
المزيد من العصا والجزرات
من تنامي العمليات ضد اسرائيل في الضفه
الغربيه اي مؤشر قد يعطيه فيما يتعلق
بتصاعد سياسات اليمين وتحكمها في السياسات
الامنيه استراتيجيه الامنيه للحكومه
الاسرائيليه
هذا يظهر لك انه لا يوجد حل عسكري
لاسرائيل بالمناسبه كانه لا يوجد حل
عسكريا للفلسطينيين كذلك هم ايضا لا يبدو
انهم يحققون اي تقدم ربما هم يجب ان
يستفيدون من حركه الديمقراطيه في اسرائيل
ويقومون بعمليه
احتجاج غير عنفيه او سلميه وطبعا عن قتل
اسرائيليين هنا وهناك كل كم اسبوع مره لن
يؤدي الى نتيجه كلا الطرفان يحتاجوا الى
اعاده تفكير تماما في موقفه بالعوده الى
حديثك عن الخطر بانهيار اسرائيل هذه
التعديلات القضائيه والتمسك بها الى اي
مدى تؤدي الى انقسام عميق وحقيقي في
المجتمع
الاسرائيلي
وتهدد حتى يعني ثبات المؤسسه الامنيه
سمعنا كثيرا على سبيل المثال الالاف من
جنود الاحتياط الذين يرفضون القيام الان
بالاعمال المتعلقه بالتطوع للجيش
اسرائيل فقط
ستنجح وفعلت ذلك فقط مع تنوع المجتمع على
اساس ان تعيش وتدعى الاخرين يعيشون لا
غالب ولا مغلوب طبعا انت لديك القدس وانا
لدي تل ابيب امتلك هذا وانا لهذا وهكذا
لكن هذه الحكومه الجديده
اسست مبادئ جديده في الحوكمه واحدها
ينطبق كما فعل بعض الديكتاتورين في
افريقيا وهو القول بانه هذا هذا ليس وقتكم
لمشاركتنا الطعام اذا لا احد سياكل
ابتعدوا عن مفهم عن عن مفهومه عش ودع
الاخرين يعيشون الى هذا المفهوم الجديد
هذا لم ينجح في لبنان ولن ينجح في اسرائيل
ليس مع هذا التنوع السكاني الكاتب الصحفي
الامريكي توماس فريد من شكرا جزيلا لك
للحديث الينا في الحصاد على شاشه الجزيره